Рік тому на вже хрестоматійних дебатах на стадіоні
перед другим туром президентських виборів кандидат Володимир Зеленський
заявив своєму високопосадовому супернику Петру Порошенку:
Я - не політик, зовсім не політик, я - просто людина,
проста людина,
яка прийшла зламати цю систему.
Я - результат, Петру Олексійовичу,
ваших помилок і обіцянок.
Тепер, через рік після перемоги на виборах,
вже сам Зеленський - результат своїх помилок й обіцянок.
Які три основні здобутки і три провали можна зарахувати
до першого року президентства Зеленського?
На думку опитаних DW експертів,
що можна назвати його здобутками,
одночасно є і провалами.
І ось чому.
Одне з головних досягнень Зеленського - кардинальне оновлення політичних еліт.
Склад Верховної Ради змінився
більше, ніж на 80 відсотків.
До влади прийшли нові обличчя.
Оновлення справді було потрібним і був величезний запит на це у суспільстві.
Але водночас за рік сталася і
руйнація міфу про нові обличчя.
Виявилося, що нові не завжди означає кращі та більш ефективні.
На думку політологів, найбільша проблема Зеленського -
слабкість кадрової політики.
І це було неминуче, оскільки фактично
в нього не було власної команди, коли він прийшов до влади,
і не було досвіду формування політичної команди.
Все робилося поспіхом.
Тому в оточенні президента та у фракції "Слуга народу" одночасно є і патріотично налаштовані,
і ті, хто в тій чи іншій формі підтримує відновлення відносин з Росією,
є ліберали і популісти.
Словом, дуже "різношерста"компанія.
У фракції "Слуга народу" дуже багато нормальних людей,
які дійсно хочуть працювати на державу,
які не пов’язані з будь-якими олігархічними колами.
З іншого боку, це люди зовсім без досвіду.
Є також дуже потужні центри впливу,
які пов’язані з Коломойським, пов’язані також з Аваковим.
Ці люди не хочуть реформ, вони хочуть блокувати,
і це - велика проблема.
Зеленський і далі експериментує з кадровою політикою
і робить це, на думку оглядачів, наосліп, методом проб і помилок,
не маючи чіткої кадрової політики.
Три останні роки до обрання Зеленського
переговори щодо Донбасу, по суті, були заблоковані.
Зеленському ж вдалося зрушити з місця мирний процес.
У грудні минулого року в Парижі відбулася зустріч лідерів"нормандської четвірки"
й особисте знайомство Зеленського з Путіним.
І, найголовніше, в Україну вдалося повернути захоплених Росією
у Керченській протоці моряків, політв’язнів Кремля,
серед яких український режисер Олег Сенцов,
а також понад сто інших полонених - загалом три хвилі обмінів.
Це велике досягнення, вважають німецькі експерти.
Але разом з тим зауважують, що в Зеленського немає чіткої стратегії
щодо компромісів з Росією.
Обміняли для російського боку людей,
які зовсім не пов’язані з Донбасом,
але пов’язані із загальним наступом Росії на Україну.
І це дуже небезпечно. Бо Росія постійно також через Крим,
кримських татар робить об’ємний фонд,
щоб грати з обміном.
Я не бачу тут стратегії.
Як Україна підходить?
Які критерії для цих обмінів?
Досі не вщухають дискусії, якою була ціна обміну полоненими для України
і які приховані поступки на користь Кремля
ще можуть з часом розкритися.
У Зеленського була романтична надія, якщо він приведе до влади
нові незаангажовані обличчя, вони швидко вирішать усі проблеми.
Але проблеми виявилися настільки серйозними, що, на думку оглядачів,
наскоком, кавалерійською атакою
їх не вирішити.
Справді, в турборежимі вдалося скасувати депутатську недоторканість
та ухвалити чимало реформаторських законів.
Зокрема, повернули норму про нелегальне збагачення чиновників.
Є нарешті зрушення з так званим "антиколомойським" законом,
аби унеможливити повернення "Приватбанку" олігарху.
Але ключові проблеми з корупцією та економікою залишаються,
нині ще й множаться на світову фінансову кризу через коронавірус.
На думку оглядачів, найбільше випробування економічною кризою чекає Зеленського восени.
Німецькі експерти також окремо акцентують
на важливості судової реформи та правоохоронних органів.
Без стабільних інститутів правової держави
не буде достатньо довіри від інвесторів -
як закордонних,
так і українських.
Дуже важливо мати стабільно функціонуючу судову систему,
щоб були інвестиції.
Це дуже потрібно для України,
після коронавірусу, щоб вийти з кризи.
Перший рік виявився для Зеленьского своєрідною "учебкою":
він набрався політичного досвіду,
переглянув деякі свої підходи щодо кадрової політики.
Але, схоже, Зеленський досі немає чіткого бачення,
як рухатися далі, і діє в режимі пожежної команди, вважають оглядачі.